استقبال حاشد وتكريم ملكي لاسود الاطلس
وماسك يبحث عن احمق للخلافه في رئاسه
تويتر و25 سؤال مع جوده عزيز اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
وصل امس اسود الاطلس المنتخب المغربي الى
البلاد قديمين من قطر بعد انجاز تاريخي في
المونديال حققوا في المركز الرابع ليكون
اول فريق عربي افريقي بحقيقه هذه الانجاز
المنتخب بالحافله المكشوفه في شوارع
الرباط وسط حشود كبيره جاءت لالقاء التحيه
وتحتفل معهم بالفوز
[تصفيق]
ومن بعد الجوله ووصل الاسود الاطلس الى
القصر الملكي اللي في العاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس واللي كان لافت في
الاستقبال الملكي هو حضور اللاعبين مع
امهاتهم الى حفل الاستقبال في القصر وكان
الملك اعطى وسام العرش من درجه قائد لكل
من رئيس الجامعه الملكيه لكره القدم ومدرب
المنتخب وكمان منح وسام العرش من درجه
ضابط للاعبي المنتخب المغربي كما امر
العاهل المغربي باعطاء اعضاء الطاقه
التقني والطبي في المنتخب او سمه ملكيه
[موسيقى]
ومن بعد التكريم خطف اللاعب اشرف حكيمي
ووالدته الاضواء واللي هم اساسا من بدايه
المونديال وهم حديث الناس بسبب اللقطات
العفويه والعلاقه الرائعه اللي بتجمع
الابن وامه فبعد التكريم توجه اللاعبين
لتناول العشاء
لحظات لاشرف حكيمي مع والدته اصبح فيها
حديث السوشيال ميديا
[موسيقى]
ومن المركز الرابع الاول والمنتخب
الارجنتيني الحلقه الثانيه مع لحظات وصوله
الى العاصمه بيونس ايرس واستعرضنا معكم
الحسود اللي كانوا في استقبال الابطال
والمشاهدات كانت اول مشاهد كانت حقيقه
تفوق الخيال صراحه وخلال الاستقبال كان في
مجموعه من اللقطات الدراميه اللي صارت مع
الفريق ومع الحسود اللي كانوا متواجدين في
الفريق طبعا يتجول في الشوارع وبالقي
التحيه على الحشود وهم على متن حافله
مكشوفه وفي لحظه الاحتفال كان راح يتحول
لكارثه ومسي وزملائه لحقوا حالهم في
اللحظه الاخيره
وينكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جدا
الاسعاف الرجال المستمر في الكتاب
واختام الدراما كان بتغيير خطه الاحتفال
فجاه فمن بعد ما كان مقرر انه الفريق يلقي
التحيه على الحشود ويكمل طريقه بالحافله
المكشوفه ليوصل الى وسط العاصمه تغيرت
الخطه تماما لانه من بعد ثلاث ساعات
الحافله ما قدرت توصل الالثلث الطريق وصلت
لمرحله ما عاد تقدر تكمل طريقها بسبب عدد
البشر اللي يقدر باربعه فاصله سبعه مليون
شخص متخيلين الرقم التقديرات في الاول
كانت التجمعات حتكون يعني مئات الالوف مو
اكثر ولما اجتمع ملايين انتهت الحلول على
الارض واخذوا اللاعبين بمروحيه وسلم على
الناس من السماء
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
اي تامه فيندو اللي بالكبتله
[موسيقى]
خلال الاستقبال موقف بخص حارس مرمى
المنتخب الارجنتيني مليان ومارتينيز لعمل
حاله من الجدل بسبب حركات السخريه لجالس
بيعملها ضد المنتخب الفرنسي وخصوصا ضد
اللاعب كيليان مبابي من بعد الجدل اللي
عملوه بسبب الحركه اعتبروها الفرنسيين غير
لائقه بحقهم في الملعب من بعد الفوز بكاس
العالم وطبعا ما بنقدر ان احنا نعرضها
صراحه يعني من الاخر يعني ومن بعد الفيديو
اللي كمان انت متداوله في غرفه تغيير
الملابس الخاصه بمنتخبه وهو جالس بيقول
دقيقه صمت على روح امبابي الميت امس كمان
عمل حركه جديده فيها سخريه من مبابي بظهر
خلال الاحتفالات وهو حامل دميه على صوره
بطاقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
موقف حارس المرمى الارجنتيني هذا عامل جدل
وانقسام على فكره ففي ناس شايفه احتفال
وعادي ومبرر وناس شايفته يعني اوفر وما في
روح رياضيه ومهين ايضا لزميله
من بعد ساعات من الصمت والامتناع عن
التغريد والترقب الناس لحسابه بخصوص اعلان
تنحي خرج الى الماسك عن صمته وفجر مفاجاه
جديده للناس
منتظر قرار تنحي يكون هو اللي نشر استطلاع
انه يتنحى او لا وصوت اكثر من 10 ملايين
شخص مع قرار انه يتنحها وكان هو قبلها وعد
الناس انه راح يلتزم بنساء اجهاد
الاستطلاع اللي هو حطوا طلع له الماسك
وقال ان هو ملتزم بالنتائج الاستطلاع بس
ما راح يتنعها الا لما نلاقي شخص احمق
كفايه علشان يستلم رئاسه تويتر بداله وقال
انه بعدها راح هو يدير فقط البرمجيات
والخواتم فقط وطبعا التغريده اللي ناشرها
ماسك واعلن فيها هذا القرار ما كانت اول
تغريده بيعلق فيها على مجرى التصويت اللي
واضح ما كان ماشي في صالحه فهو في الاول
رد على احد متابعينه واللي يقول انه من
المثير مقارنه عدد الاصوات بعدد الاعجا
قالت لي انه بيطرح السؤال هل سيطر البوتس
على نتائج الاستطلاع وفور الرد عليه ماسك
انه هذه ملاحظه مثيره للاهتمام
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقتنا اليوم
وهذه الاسبوع
واستثنائيا راح تكون معنا فقره 25 سؤال
الاربعاء بدل من الخميس مثل المعتاد فتنه
هذا الاسبوع الفنانه جود عزيز اما غدا
المشاهدين فانتظرون في حلقه خاصه حنلف
فيها سواء على كل اللي غطيناه وتكلمنا عنه
في تفاعلكم هذه السنه يعني ملخص تفاعلكم
20 22 في حلقه خاصه
تابعونا ان شاء الله وفي امان الله
جود عزيز 25 سؤال لازم جواب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير كيف انشهرتي
فتحت حساب في الانستغرام
[موسيقى]
ااا اول شايف البدايه كنت ابغى هذا
الموضوع اصلا يبقى خصوصيه بيننا لكن الناس
اكتشفت كل شيء فخلاص طلع للناس وبما انه
خلاص تم الانفصال همم فالحمد لله على كل
حال والله يوفق الجميع يارب العالمين
اتمنى لك الخير بس انتم تركتوا ورجعتم
وتركتم ورجعتم قدام الناس
انا مالي دخل قصدك انه هو اللي كتب
البوستات يعني
اوكي طيب ليش تركته
الله يوفق الجميع خلاص اوكي
الحمدلور قدمتيه اهم دور قدمتها
امم
شخصيه فخريه في مسلسل الجنيه اللي انعرض
على شاهد اوكي لبست الحجاب وقلتي هتبعدي
وبعدين خلعتيه والناس اتهامتك انك عملت
هذه كله عشان المشاهدات اول شيء ابدا
اوكي بس النمو على المشاهدات
اكيد يعني بس انه قصدي
بحث عن الاذان
يعني ان شاء الله امورك
اقدر اقول بس
انا ما عندي احد معين حتى ولا احد عالمي
ممكن تقولي اسم عالمي اذا بتحرج انه مثلا
احد عربي
انا احفظ وجهي اوكي طيب
صعب جدا
نقله دبي هنا بدون اهلي
ما كان في شيء اقصى من كده الحمد لله طيب
رجعتي نشرتي بعد ارتباطك بطلال باسم قبل
ما تتركوه فيديو قديم بتتكلمي فيه او
بتكلمي في نفسك في المراه
حوار مع النفس الناس صراحه سخروا منك كثير
على هذا الموضوع وهذا الفكره
الفيديو حبيبي
[موسيقى]
20 اوكي بس مثلا يعني الواحد يكون مثلا
عمل فني هالو اعلان هو يعني ايش يكون كيفك
كيف شيء يكون عالمي يوصلك العالميه
الطرفين ممكن كده
بس انك انت رايحه للعالمين اوكي هل بتزوري
طبيب نفسي
[ضحك]
اه انفلونسر بلوجر ما ادري يعني همم
مجموعه انسان يمكن مجموعه انسان اوكي طيب
كيف بتردي على اللي يقول لك محتوى كافه
اخر كتاب قراتيه
ايش كان اسمه يا ربي
فقدان الذاكره اوكي
انت كذا طيحتيني ليه
نجمات من اي ناحيه
نجمه الفنان الاولى في السعوديه
اثنين اثنين بس
انا صراحه يعني ما اغار من المواضيع
العاديه
في المستقبل
طيب كان ممكن اليوم تكوني مليونيره بس انت
صريفه جدا لقيت درجه هذا الكلام صحيح مين
قال
يعني
بيوجعك يا جود على طول
اوكي طيب تخافي من العين يعني طيب صحباتك
قولي له بيتغيروا قله ثقه منك في الناس او
تقلب شخصيتك او المشكله منه
وبعدين او انا اكتشف شخصياتهم متاخر
بتحسي انه المشكله في الناس اتمنى يعني
ههه لان ده صارت المشكله مني ما ادري شو
راح اسوي ههه
اعجبتني هذه الاشاره اوكي طيب يا ريت هم
اللي يطلعوا المشكله طيب اغنيه عبر عن
حياتك او حالتك النفسيه اه
حاليا ولا بشكل عام حاليا مثلا بشكل عمتي
الاثنين اللي يعجبك بشكل عام في اغنيه
اليسا بس نسيت اسم الاغنيه بالضبط ذكرهالق
اليسا ايش الكلمات همم
انا من جوايا عكس اللي شايفينها ما اعرف
اسم الاغنيه بس هذه ههه
طيب اوكي هذه اللي تعبر عنك بشكل
عام هذه بشكل عام حاليا
ها
العجل
ان شاء الله اكيد كلنا عندنا عجول في ناس
ما تستخدم عقلهم بالطريقه الصحيحه فانا
اتمنى ان عاقل عاقل
شكرا لك
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]